ok next game or the CM yeah she's from
Canada but something Russian maybe okay
night f3m we should be five or so played
much more often not sure maybe if for
not sure this is a good idea you have to
move look at the passive okay
get him to take on c6 not sure what is
sound thinking about ya okay this was a
possible move but its own it's also
strange move I think we had hard to
believe that he could afford that don't
think there are any tricks working here
like when your note-taking and queens
you for something always a fish would be
seven the young okay
can I don't really want to take now
maybe if I we give the check first to
provoke c3 or some movie that certainly
doesn't want to play nazi three looks
just silly ok let's check now what what
what about d5 let's say d5 you take see
I take f5 it takes g7 I will treat the
bishop and the night doesn't have any
square this an idea I try that ok maybe
taking here some it's quite okay for
white could be yeah but where does he go
if I just retreat the bishop now the
thing doesn't have any squares besides
h5 I completely overlooked the simple
Mafia great a great of course he's got
age five
oh dear okay maybe it's still somewhat
playable position I'm better developed
and maybe I have some ideas here he
cannot easily am continue you think
try to use the white squares here also
Bishop g2 f3 get rid of this Bishop I
might have a very nice square d 3 yeah
now a threatened yeah okay but now I
have this annoying check here and now
Queen f5 was my idea to h3 then this
should be dangerous this should be
dangerous
maybe he needs to play something like
rook g2 now now this was maybe the only
move okay what now I can pick up the
exchange but i'm not sure i want that
I want to keep the pressure here and
keep the diagonal close TM it's not able
to remove this here anyway I think okay
still he cannot take
Brooke would be just trapped here if he
if he took now and if he moves the Queen
I have queen edge three look f6 rook f6
to threaten tweenage three-time warning
ok let's let's keep it simple just
friend Bishop g2
you cannot play Bishop f1 for instance
because the queen is just hanging ok
take on h2 top first
we need to play am king of one okay
something better here even okay let's
take this
just 23 seconds netted the bishop needs
to go to it back to the sixes Sookie
move get the route to h2
ja yeah this was understandable to get
some color chances on the long diagonal
still I don't see you really fence check
check this wasn't strongest most post
probably check check check terrible to
lose this game i just spent too much
time black forfeits on time um okay
where did i have some hm this is really
disappointing him ja let's check this
here unbelievable
sure i have cost Queen f3 and just a
rogue h1 yeah I didn't have much time
still it's easier oh okay no okay let's
play another game